reason to believe the russian forces are
planning to and intend to attack ukraine
on friday joe biden stunned many of the
us's allies by categorically stating
that vladimir putin had made up his mind
to invade ukraine in the coming days and
on sunday the president convened a
meeting of his national security council
to discuss the situation ahead of that
meeting the u.s secretary of state
reaffirmed that despite the president's
announcement diplomacy was still an
option until it's settled uh until we
know that uh the uh the tanks are
rolling the planes are flying and uh the
aggression has uh has fully begun we're
gonna do everything we can to prevent it
but we're prepared either way and we're
prepared with a response that will have
massive consequences for russia if it
actually carries this through lincoln
said he hoped a forthcoming meeting this
week with his russian counterpart would
address both preventing war and
addressing mutual security concerns for
the u.s europe and russia
the russian and ukrainian ambassadors to
the us were also on the sunday talk show
circuit anatoly antonov denied any
invasion of ukraine was planned he said
moscow's priority was the implementation
of the minsk agreement which was
designed permanently to stop the war in
ukraine's east by among other things
giving the region some autonomy the
united states it's very easy to stop
such crisis you have to persuade
kiev to fulfill minsk agreement that's
all the ukrainian ambassador said
whether russia invaded or not her
country was already at war but still
held out the possibility of a diplomatic
solution we are calling not only on
aggressor which is russia but also on
all of our friends and allies to get
together and use every opportunity to
still deter russia from invading
hanging over the discussion as always
the us's past declarations in the run-up
to war
how confident are you given what's
happened in the past with afghanistan
with iraq are you absolutely confident
in the intelligence you're seeing now we
have high confidence in uh in in the
things that we're looking at of course
you know in terms of
being
able to predict exactly what's going to
happen going forward you know you never
can the french say that the summit
agreed to in principle by the us and
russia won't just be about ukraine but
about security and strategic stability
in europe as a whole
the white house says it was always
committed to diplomacy as long as there
was no invasion but added as far as it
was concerned it was still seeing
preparations for a russian assault very
soon but that's less specific than the
president was on friday shia britancy al
jazeera washington